哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天很開心
來到了大家一直很期待的
影劇分析喔
就是我們今天就是要討論一個角色
那這個角色是哪一個角色呢
我不知道大家最近有沒有在看
目前有一點點夯的一個韓劇
叫做夢想成為律師的律師們
那時候剛開始
一個韓劇在播的時候
我就開始看
我不知道他居然是
每一個禮拜上兩集
我最討厭這種慢慢更新的
但是因為後來就入坑了
所以後來知道乖乖的
每個禮拜追劇喔
在看這一部劇的時候
當然裡面有很多角色
我都很喜歡
之後有機會我想跟大家分享
不過裡面呢
我感覺到最深刻
我也最喜歡的那個角色呢是
裡面的一個
訴訟組的女律師
然後因為是年紀比較大
後來才轉律師這一行
然後42歲現在是一個
算獨當裡面的一個律師喔
就是許敏貞
我對這個角色感受很深刻
是因為他這個角色的刻畫
非常非常的就是
特別
本來是一個就是
念書念得很好的女孩子
後來就是懷孕了結婚
結婚之後被
婆家虐待然後離婚
考上律師然後現在就是
過得跟以前不一樣生活
這感覺非常的勵志
但是我在看他整個這一路的過程
我有感覺到非常符合
我們在內耗的這一門課裡面
講到的一些
我們的生存策略的
一個變化的一個理由
我很想跟大家分享
許敏貞律師
他從以前到現在到底發生了什麼事
那為什麼他會從
一個原本就是會被欺負的人
後來變成一個
他其實可以很為自己的一些狀況
很為自己的界限去捍衛
他做到了什麼
為什麼他能夠做到這些
所以我想跟大家分享關於
這一個角色的特色
我們先看許敏貞這個角色
他原本的家庭環境
他的父親很早就過世了
然後他跟他的媽媽相依為密
看得出來他媽媽跟他感情很好
因為他會跟他媽媽去旅行
並且他在夢到他媽媽的時候
他跟他媽媽互動其實是很不錯的
在這種就是母女關係比較親近
而且母親其實是很願意開放的去表達
去表達自己的一些情緒
跟感受的時候
你看到他們母女的情緒連結這麼高
於是你就會瞭解到許敏貞
他在早期的狀態其實是比較接近
高功能的討好型
討好型不是說他很愛討好別人
不是的
意思是
他在跟他人互動中已經很習慣
如果我今天去符合別人的需求
去照顧別人的情感
別人也會相對應的這樣對我
所以我今天去為了對方做比較多
甚至稍微有退讓界限
或犧牲界限的事情
其實沒有那麼不安全
因為對方也會這麼去回應我
去讓我感受到我是被愛的
我是被照顧的他為我犧牲一些東西
所以我為了他 我也要回報一些東西
這個部分在他之前的生存策略
其實是相對安全的
所以對他來說他是高功能討好型
可是高功能討好型
我們在內耗的這門課裡面有講到
不管是討好型跟疏遠型
他們都對一個東西很敏感
就是他人的情緒
也就是說他是很能夠從他人的情緒
去調整自己要怎麼跟別人互動的
最後來就是對於許敏貞來說
有一個非常大的打擊
那就是在他大學要畢業的時候
我不太確定是要畢業的時候
還是畢業後總之差不多那個時間
媽媽過世了
然後他可能也是差不多時間
認識那一個時候的前夫
然後懷孕了
結果就踏入了婚姻
這對他來說其實是
一個很合邏輯的事情
講句實話他念了那麼好的書
有這麼好的學歷
他的第一個反應既然不是去工作
而是因為就是懷孕了
他就決定要去要結婚
然後去生小孩
然後踏入婚姻這件事情
有一個非常重要的關鍵
那就是如果他之前跟母親的關係
的確有比較多是
成功不必在我
我的努力不是要發展我自己
而是要讓媽媽放心
讓媽媽開心
讓媽媽覺得好
也就是說以他人為需求這件事情
對他來說是一個很習慣的
一個生存策略
他在後來懷孕之後
他會考慮比較多人的需求
於是放棄自己想要發展的未來
踏入家庭
就是一個非常容易可以理解的選擇
但是進入他婆家的這個環境
加上媽媽離開之後
他獲得了一個非常大的挫折感
那就是他的婆家環境
並不是會尊重並且照顧他需求的人
甚至他婆家環境是非常惡劣的
是會傷害他
然後覺得他很沒有用
然後否定他
以至於他的情緒越來越多
而他又不是一個習慣
就是會直接用對抗的方式
或是用直接表達的方式
讓對方知道需求
因此他就會用他原本的策略
那就是盡可能去做好每件事
盡可能看別人的需求是什麼
就是很高功能的
然後去忍耐自己的感受
去照顧別人的感情
照顧別人的感受
就是比較討好型的
然後讓自己盡可能去做到
別人想要的事情
然後讓自己的狀況越來越差
因為他注意力不是在自己身上
這就是一個非常標準的
我們用以前的生存策略
在現在惡劣的環境生存
用以前一樣可以
就是奏效的生存策略
卻在現在的這個生存環境中
是沒辦法奏效的
所以這就是那時候
許敏貞他遇到的第一個困境
那這時候還會有一個困境
那就是以前他在跟他媽媽的互動中
媽媽是會給他感受的
媽媽是會給他情感支持的
因此他對媽媽做的那些
也許有一點犧牲
也許有點以媽媽為主的這個部分
他不會感覺到這麼空洞
這麼痛苦或是這麼忍耐
因為媽媽會給他回應
讓他這感覺到
這一切是有價值的
是值得的
可是當他現在在婆家這個狀態
他不停的被羞辱的情況之下
他有很多很多情緒
但是他必須要忍耐
他不能發作
所以他必須要一直忍下來
這個情緒忍下來之後
很容易會出現一些類似藥酒飲
或是有些人會喝酒
有些人會吃東西
有些人會買東西
他很容易會轉為另外一些
物質失調的一些狀態
呈現在他們的生活當中
而許敏貞用的方式就是吃東西
因為吃東西對那個時候的
它是最簡單的
因為畢竟它是
可能家裡負責煮飯的人
所以呢
要拿到食物吃東西
準備食物對他來說
都是相對簡單
於是他就開始
就是用吃東西來
宣洩他的壓力跟痛苦
實際上食物這件事情
是很容易人在壓力的時候
會選擇拿來
宣洩情緒跟就是
壓力痛苦的一個物質
原因是因為糖本身
就是一個上癮品
他就是會讓你上癮
這是一個非常基本的一個東西
再加上吃這件事情
就像許敏貞他夢到媽媽
夢到媽媽在煮飯給他吃
吃這件事情
在台灣 在韓國
是不是全世界我不能確定
但是在
大部分的亞洲國家
能夠有吃到東西
別人準備給你吃
那是一個最基本的愛的展現
那是最基本的情感的福味
這是我們從小學到的事情
這就像是阿嬤看到你
第一句話就是吃飽沒
就是這種感覺
台南的阿嬤
最喜歡就是
我以前就是也沒有很瘦
有一陣子胖到一個不行
然後回去找阿嬤的時侯
阿嬤就抓著我的小小手
就說哎喲
好瘦喔
他媽媽都會哭
就是阿嬤的這個狀態
所以吃這件事情
是我們在從小的情感狀態中
很容易感受到可以被安撫
被照顧
然後情緒可以下降的一個
很常見的一個方式
因此對於那個時候
很寂寞很寂寞的許敏貞
他的媽媽是離開了
他的丈夫不理解他
他的婆婆虐待他
他的女兒看不起他
在這麼多痛苦的地方
沒有人看重他的犧牲
他沒有任何的價值
在這種情況之下
唯有食物是唯一他可控
而且能夠撫慰他
讓他感覺到不那麼寂寞
讓他可以想念他媽媽的一種方式
這其實是很難過的一件事
那當然啦
就是生命會自己找到出口的意思
就是當你痛苦到一個時候
決定要改變這個人生
決定要改變這個狀態的時候
他就做了一個改變
其實這也代表這本來
許敏貞的內在就有一點點
也是有點對抗型的這個能力
所以他決定要改變自己的人生
所以他做了一個調整
他決定要離婚
他也離婚了
然後開始大量的運動
然後不停的訓練自己
然後認識了就是裡面的男主角
於是他就可以就是慢慢的
進入一個很棒的事務所
然後展現出他的能力
讓他可以在這個事務所
就是有一席之地
這時候我們就會看
開始變生了的許敏貞
他變成另外一個型
他變成什麼型
他變成高功能疏遠型
雖然說後來他婆家來
他對他婆家就是對他婆婆
還有對他老公罵得很兇
看起來就是很兇很有點像對抗型
但那個只是他一時間
表現出來的樣子
大部分許敏貞他在
平常日常生活中展現的樣子
更像是高功能疏遠型
他並沒有非常的
我一定要贏 我什麼都要第一名
到沒有但是他非常需要
每件事情都做好
然後他對人就比較不假詞色
他不需要用討好的方式
用好好他對於他喜歡的人
他還是會做這樣的事情
可是他並不會故意的
必須要去討好就是權威啊
幹嘛的所以他就是比較
用自己的步調在做事
但是我怎麼我為什麼說
他是疏遠型呢 我相信有看這部劇的
很多人可能都已經發現了
他在裡面跟另外一個男律師的一個
戀愛就是曖昧的那個狀態
還有他自己在想到他媽媽
然後非常非常難受的狀態
他都是要自己躲起來哭
以及當他面對那個
另外那個李律師對他的一個喜歡
然後想要跟他再親近一點
親近一點他考慮到
因為他離過婚了
而且呢他現在就是
跟這個李律師的年紀差了10歲
所以他完全不想 不希望
跟他有任何的就是親密關係的時候
他用的方式不是跟對方講清楚
而是用一直逃避的方式
去面對對方對他的追求
還有希望跟他的親近
就是一個非常標準的疏遠型
並且他會把話講得比較難聽啊
希望對方知難而退
等等
那這就很有趣了
為什麼許敏貞會從就是
我們剛剛講的就是高功能討好型
變成高功能疏遠型呢
嚴格來說這件事情並不難
怎麼說並不難呢
原因是因為其實生存策略很容易
會因為生存環境的變化
甚至很大巨大的創傷事件
讓我們有很大的轉變
例如說我原本是一個討好型
結果我後來發現
做這些什麼用都沒有
只會讓別人欺負你
所以我再也不要去感受到這個痛苦
這個痛苦讓我實在是不想要再面對了
所以我決定我的大腦
會讓我決定OK
我為了要避免這個痛苦
我要選另外一條路
而實際上討好型跟疏遠型
他們其實是算同一套
他們是同個系列
他們算是雙胞胎
雙胞胎姐妹或兄弟
只是他們做的方法不同
因為會引起他們敏感度的東西
都是一樣的
那就是別人的情緒
很有趣的地方是討好型跟疏遠型
雖然他們看起來策略差很多
討好型是好像跟別人有
很有善、很親切、有很親近的相處
而疏遠型好像
有一點點距離或是有一點界線感
等等
可是實際上他們都會
對別人的情緒敏感度
非常高
也就是說會引發他們焦慮
或是造成他們壓力的東西
很多都跟情緒有關
我有情緒的時候
別人有情緒的時候
別人表情有一些狀態的時候
這些東西都可能會引發他們的
生存策略、產生
只是疏遠型就是你有情緒
我不管你
然後討好型就是你有情緒
我要趕快照顧你
可是另外一個部分是
我有情緒的時候
我該怎麼做呢
對於疏遠型來說
我有情緒的時候
我必須要一個人處理
我不能讓別人看到
我這個情緒的樣子
這件事情就是疏遠型
非常標準的狀況
也就是說平常他看起來
都非常非常好
可是只要你要親近他
或是有情緒的時候
他看起來就會變成另外一個人
這個就是他討好型的
討好型的
另外一個反動
所以我覺得討好型跟疏遠型
他會有這樣的轉變
非常非常能夠理解
而這也就是為什麼
他變成一個這麼像逃避型的人
他就偏偏配了一個焦慮型
他會一直去追他
一直去要求他
沒有錯 那個李律師
就是非常標準的焦慮型
就是很像狗狗一樣
會一直跟
對方就會一直跑
他們就會形成這樣的狀態
可是我覺得
這一個東西
也是一個非常重要的關鍵
那就是我們要怎麼樣
可以讓自己瞭解
也許我以前
有一些創傷的經驗
讓我知道
我是會有危險的
我不能再用
以前那個生存策略
跟每個人相處
可是我仍然能夠保有
一定的彈性
就是讓我自己
有的時候可以展現一些情緒
感受
以及可以展現
我自己真正的樣子
這一件事情
許敏貞在跟李律師
還有跟訴訟組的
這些朋友們
這些律師們的相處
慢慢的去放鬆
自己可以說出自己的感受
自己可以說出自己的心情
包含當他有女兒來
就是見到他
然後呢
本來就是看起來
也是有點冷漠冷漠的
然後後來就叫了他一聲媽
這就是標準
疏遠型會覺得很開心
很感動
但是他不會表現出來
這就是為什麼
我說疏遠型跟討好型
會讓他們動容的東西
都是一樣的
不管是引發他們焦慮也好
讓他們感動也好
喜歡的東西也好
不喜歡的東西也好
其實是一樣的
只是
討好型
就像是你可以把
情緒當成炸彈
別人的負面情緒
自己的負面情緒
都是炸彈
只是討好型很習慣
就是在別人有負面情緒的時候
因為他常常拆彈成功
所以他就是主動的
拆別人這個情緒的炸彈
去安撫對方
去照顧對方
然後這樣子
可能就不會爆炸了
這就是討好型的做法
疏遠型就是他的經驗
就是他經驗過
不管你怎麼做對方都會爆炸
這個東西是太不可控
那個感覺太無助了
所以他最後的方式
就是把自己弄成一個防護牆
就是不管怎樣
你爆炸了
不要炸到我就好
所以你從許敏貞
他從以前他的經驗
到後來他在婆家的經驗
你就可以理解
為什麼他會從高功能討好型
變成高功能疏遠型的
這個狀態其實就是一個
非常大的差別
不過雖然我覺得
就是如果用這樣的方式
去說的話
雖然許敏貞他以前在婆家
可能是高功能討好
可是我覺得那個討好
仍然只有策略
而不是思考跟想法
原因是因為他其實那個時候
也不擅長說出自己真正的感受
也就是對於說感受這件事情
他一向都是不擅長的
所以到了後面
他開始可以跟別人分享
關於他女兒的事情
還有他結過婚的事情
他對很多事情的感受
那感覺是什麼
他可以感覺到
他在分享這件事情的時候
不管是李律師也好
或者是我們就是裡面
另外一個女主角
江律師也好
他們都是沒有任何評價的
聽他說這些事情
這件事也讓他對於這個環境
越來越有安全感
越來越覺得
如果我在這裡展現出我的情緒
表達出我的喜好
應該是安全的吧
可能沒有像以前一樣那麼危險
他也就能夠辨識
以前會傷害我的人
跟現在的人是不一樣的
我不用一直用以前的那個策略
去面對我人生的每一個關係
我的策略是可以轉換的
我可以更表達我真實的感受
還有需求
這裡是有人可以接住我的
我覺得這一個部分
是非常非常重要的
所以這也是許敏貞這一個角色
因為我覺得他把這一個角色
為什麼會從之前那樣變成這樣
他的那個邏輯跟理由非常清楚
而且實在是因為我很喜歡許敏貞
他長得很漂亮
大家也可以看看
你有沒有跟我一樣的感覺呢
那你是不是也很喜歡這部劇呢
如果你喜歡的話
這部劇你有沒有想要聽我分析
誰歡迎可以留言讓我知道
今天影劇文本分析
就到這裡結束囉
希望大家喜歡我今天的分享
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見
拜拜